[Musique]
l'agent saint pierroise du cnam comité
national d'accueil et d'actions pour les
réunionnais en mobilité a inauguré ses
nouveaux locaux rue du père favron ce
mardi 11 avril une nouvelle structure
plus spacieuse afin de mieux répondre
aux attentes des demandeurs d'emploi
sudiste et d'offrir de meilleures
conditions de travail aux salariés le
cnar minogue heures ce soir sa nouvelle
antenne de savières dans des bâtiments
bien placé veut bien accessible très
confortable pour les collaborateurs et
surtout très confortable pour les
candidats au départ qui ont un
magnifique ateliers à sueur mobilité qui
ont des conditions d'accueil qui sont
exceptionnelles dont nous sommes assez
fiers une grosse bâtiment ce sport à
travers le cnam le conseil départemental
souhaite accompagner au mieux les rings
ni désir de travailler en dehors de
l'île en leur offrant les meilleures
conditions de mobilité pour un emploi
les jeunes partent en métropole pour se
former soit un contrat de qualification
soit sûr aussi des emplois donc
les entreprises sur le territoire
pauleta et reviennent ils peuvent
revenir après avec une qualification ou
autrement
amitié un vrai meeting est ce un scanner
aussi à la réunion et porter cette
dynamique au sein de la population
jeunes de leur quartier
chaque année près de 2000 renew n'est
partent avec l'aide du cnls armes parmi
20 % viennent du sud
1 pierre est une ville dynamique dans un
sud qui est dynamique donc avoir un lock
out now ici dans un quartier de la
ravine blanche qui a été entièrement
rénové avec une population qui a
augmenté avec une jeunesse qui est de
plus en plus nombreuses nombreuses à
saint-pierre nombreux dans le sud et à
la réunion le cma a toute sa place ici
le cnam compte à ce jour près d'une
centaine d'entreprises partenaires en
métropole l'année dernière sur les 1020
personnes parties en prospection
d'emploi 61% ont trouvé un travail
[Musique]